[Music]
what is this funny oh okay it's such an
honor to present this next award the
five men I'm still watching you the five
men nominated in this category delivered
resonating evocative and captivating
performances here are the nominees for
performance by an actor in a leading
role
Christian Bale American hustle Bruce
Dern Nebraska Leonardo DiCaprio the wolf
of Wall Street
Chiwetel Ejiofor 12 years of slave
Matthew McConaughey Dallas buyers club
and the Oscar goes to Matthew
McConaughey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you to the Academy for this all
6,000 members thank you to the other
nominees all these performances were
impeccable in my opinion I didn't see a
false note anywhere I want to thank
shell Mark valet our director want to
thank trade Leto
Jennifer Garner or worked with Daley um
there's a few things about three things
to my account that I need each day one I
miss something to look up to another is
something to look forward to and another
is someone to chase now first off I want
to thank God because that's who I look
up to
he's graced my life with opportunities
that I know are not of my hand or any
other human hand he has shown me that
it's a scientific fact that gratitude
reciprocates in the words of a late
Charlie Lawton who said when you got God
you got a friend and that friend is you
to my family that's who and what I look
forward to to my father who I know he's
up there right now with a big pot of
gumbo he's got a lemon meringue pie over
there he's probably in his underwear
he's got a cold can of Miller Lite he's
dancing right
do you dad you taught me what it means
to be a man to my mother who's here
tonight who taught me and my two older
brothers demanded that we respect
ourselves and what we in turn learned
was then we were better able to respect
others thank you for that mama - my wife
Camilla and my kids Levi
Peeta mr. stone the courage and
significance you give me every day I go
out the door is unparalleled you are the
four people in my life I want to make
the most proud of me thank you
and to my hero that's who I chase now
when I was fifteen years old I had a
very important person in my life come to
me and say who's your hero and I said I
got to think about that give me a couple
of weeks I come back two weeks later
this person comes out and says who's
your hero I said I thought about it you
know who it is I said it's me in ten
years
so I turned twenty five ten years later
that same person comes Mingo so you're a
hero and I was like not even close no no
no she said why I said because my heroes
me at 35 so you see every day every week
every month and every year of my life my
heroes always ten years away
I'm never gonna be my hero I'm not gonna
attain that I know I'm not and that's
just fine with me because that keeps me
with somebody to keep on chasing so to
any of us whatever those things are
whatever it is we look up to whatever it
is we look forward to and whoever it is
we're chasing to that I say amen to that
I say all right all right all right hey
just keep letting him
thank you